[Music]
this is the international space station
it orbits the earth 16 times a day
250 miles up
it's where astronauts from more than a
dozen different countries have been
living since the year 2000 mostly
russians and americans
and for the last 10 years basically the
only way anyone got up or down was in a
russian soyuz
at least in space countries like russia
and the us depend on each other
but when russia invaded ukraine the u.s
levied major sanctions in response
including some meant to degrade their
aerospace industry including their space
program
the head of russia space agency
responded that perhaps they'd crashed
the space station
they even made a fake video showing
russians leaving an american astronaut
and then detaching the russian segment
relations between the west and russia
are the tensest they've been since the
international space station has been in
operation
so
what happens to it now
[Music]
[Applause]
during the cold war the u.s and the
soviet union were in the space race who
could develop the technology to reach
the stars first
but space is also where the two
countries have tried to get along
after the soviet union launched the
first satellite and put the first man
into space but before the u.s landed on
the moon
there was actually talk of going to the
moon
the together reaches of the universe
must not become the new arena of an even
colder war it actually ended up being
something discussed in congress
of course that was where it then fizzled
out it but i think
it was important that these discussions
took place it led to the two countries
eventually collaborating on a compatible
docking system even joined spacecrafts
in 1975.
the handshake was a symbol of we see
each other as equal partners in this we
recognize and respect each other at
least here in space
soon after the u.s would begin its space
shuttle program bringing astronauts and
satellites into space in reusable
shuttles and the soviet union would
create the first modular space station
mir where cosmonauts could live long
term
at the same time the u.s japan canada
and several european countries began
planning to build their own space
station together
but after the soviet union fell and the
cold war ended the us and russia began
peace talks
one of the first things they agreed to
was collaboration in space
soon u.s shuttle astronauts docked with
mir
russian cosmonauts joined shuttle
launches
and liftoff of discovery on a bold new
era of space flight between the united
states and russia and russia was added
to the joint station plans instead of
building weapons in space russian
scientists will help us to build
the international space station
the first parts of the space station
went up in 1998 it was designed to be
collaborative and interdependent it's
made up of these individual modules some
controlled by russia some controlled by
the u.s along with several other
countries
the russian side controls the navigation
and the u.s provides most of the
electricity that was a purposeful design
to sort of work in international
cooperation into the the actual
technicalities of the space station
they've conducted thousands of
experiments to learn about diseases
climate change on earth and importantly
for space exploration whether humans can
actually live in space long term
how does food grow or a human body
change
the space station is sort of this major
stepping stone for more exploration of
space going back to the moon onto mars
it's to learn about human survival in
space
and international cooperation in space
has largely worked out really well
the us even retired its shuttle program
and became completely reliant on
russia's soyuz rockets to reach the
space station
but then
russian tanks chompers and troops
vladimir putin moves to annex crimea in
2014 russia invaded and annexed crimea
from ukraine
and the u.s imposed harsh sanctions
just like he would again years later the
head of russia's ross cosminos
threatened to pull soyuz access
suggesting that the u.s should get to
the space station on a trampoline
but the two countries weren't serious
about bringing the conflict on earth to
the space station at least the head of
nasa then wasn't worried about the
tweets president obama and president
putin sort of put a bubble around the
international space station and we
continued the space diplomatic
relationship that says something about
the value of that bilateral relationship
the military has escalated its attacks
on civilians he believes russia is
committing war crimes
today the diplomatic relationship
between the u.s and russia is at the
lowest point since the cold war
but the space relationship between them
remains fairly untouched
the russians didn't leave the us
astronaut behind and brought him back to
earth in a soyuz touchdown
i never perceived those tweets as
anything to take seriously i just had
too much confidence in our cooperation
to date they even sent a new crew of
cosmonauts to the space station
people have problems on earth
on orbit we are not like we are one crew
for now the space station continues to
run mostly insulated from the
geopolitical problems on earth just as
it was designed
emphasis on for now
the truth is the space station is old it
was only designed to last until 2015 and
while the countries have agreed to
continue operations several times right
now that agreement only goes until 2024
the u.s wants to extend until 2030.
russia has yet to sign on
but even if they do the two countries
have different plans in space in the
future
private companies are planning to build
their own space stations in the coming
decade nasa wants to depend on those
they're focused on developing the
artemis program going back to the moon
establishing a presence there and
eventually traveling to mars in
collaboration with other countries
with two notable exceptions
russia is currently planning and
building its own space station
so is china who plans to finish their
station already in orbit this year
they're also planning a mission to the
moon
i think we're still going to see we must
see international cooperation in space
but the question is just which countries
will cooperate with which other
countries
as for the international space station
if russia doesn't participate after 2024
things they currently control like
navigation could be designed on the u.s
side
likely with the help of private
companies like spacex
spacex is already how many astronauts
get to the space station their first
mission in 2020 ended the dependence on
russia's soyuz the trampoline is working
[Music]
the international space station is
really one of the best examples in
history of human cooperation it can
represent the best of humanity
the war in ukraine may hasten the end of
the space station but that end was
already planned
would it really threatens is the future
of these countries finding common ground
in space
my hope is that these type of
connections can be maintained and serve
as a path forward to try to find that
common ground that we need so
desperately to find peace
[Music]